now the conservative MP and member of
the Northern Ireland Affairs committee
is Sir Robert Buckland is here with us
this morning hey how are you it's nice
to see you as always is it still going
to go ahead well it sounds like it I
mean I'm hearing been here before well
we have many times and I think a lot of
us have got the scars on our back on on
brexit it does sound as if it is
happening your first year Von delaying
is coming over this afternoon then it
does look like that the British
government and the EU have agreed a deal
which I think is really positive news
for the people of Northern Ireland
because anything that helps to deal with
the bureaucracy and the disruption that
is caused to businesses by this these
checks between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland I think is a very
positive step forward
I agree though is it well I very much
hope that the dup will approve what
comes out of the package I'm hearing
that there are potential developments on
v80 and state subsidies which are big
issues as well for uh the relationship
between the uh EU and and the UK but I I
think now is the time for us to press
ahead with a much needed change I think
that we need to think about citizens in
Northern Ireland and their lives and the
reality of life on the ground in
Northern Ireland and work together for
uh that change and whilst it'd be great
to have the dup on board I think now is
the time for us to to get on with those
reforms from what you're saying um out
can we glean that the dup is not
all-powerful like it was previously well
look I'm sure the dup MPS and mlas
themselves would not claim to be
all-powerful I think what they would say
is that they are a couple of deals
before well I mean you know we remember
when of course they held the balance of
power in that hung Parliament back in 17
that isn't the case anymore but it's not
the case that they are being
marginalized and also there's a wider
issue here about unionist opinion uh
within a Northern Ireland you know there
are many strands of uh opinion that
support Union with Great Britain with
the UK but who might take a more
pragmatic view should we say or of the
need for some compromise here you know
we must let the perfect be the enemy of
the good I'm sure that this deal will
probably have some unanswered questions
and maybe not solve all the issues in
one Fell Swoop but it does sound as if
it's going to be a big step forward that
means then we don't have to take this
unilateral action here in the UK with a
Northern Ireland protocol bill that's
currently before Parliament it sends us
to the prime minister's already got the
the top off his Mont Blanc fountain pen
but surely it needs to go to a vote in
the house here's the thing I think
technically it probably doesn't because
I think this is that's not really the
point though is there well I understand
politics okay around a long time I think
if I were the government I'd probably be
making time for a debate and for some
sort of vote that can be held by members
but I do think that as a matter of law
it is important to remember that we put
into place mechanisms in the U
withdrawal act back in 2020 that allow
for these things to have direct effect
through that already established
legislative pipeline so let's not get
too hung up about this but the idea that
some omps aren't going to have their
sales is I think for the birds I'm sure
we're going to hear a lot of uh opinion
in the next few days so you think there
will be a vote well I think there'll be
some sort of vote I I think because the
ERG will want to vote people like Boris
Johnson as Wella bravaman who are
agitating in the background they will
all want to vote yeah but the government
is right to say that they've already
established the statutory pipeline
through which any uh treaty treaties are
what does that mean for the Prime
Minister well I think it means the prime
minister is able to do his deal and and
actually act in the interest of the
people of Northern Ireland and I think
that whilst Parliament is obviously
hugely important in all of that I think
that uh ultimately you know the
government has got to be in a position
where it is able to make these
International agreements and then make
them stick and I'm sure that the
majority of the conservative party will
want the prime minister to understand
that but the Prime Minister
um has to keep the troublemakers on side
oh yes he does but also this is about
leadership and I think when you are in
these positions of leadership taking
some risks uh taking difficult decisions
grasping Nettles if you like is a really
important part of what it is to be a
leader and I think the prime minister is
demonstrating that at the moment I very
much hope that he succeeds it will be a
demonstration of his resolution and his
ability to under big pressure make those
big calls but you can only lead if you
have the support of your back benches
well I think the majority of back
benches will rally around I think that
whilst it's important to hear the voices
of everybody who like me has been Deep
In The Weeds of all of this I think
ultimately looking at the bigger picture
we've got to put ourselves in the shoes
of the people of Northern Ireland
remember that it is their interest that
we need to serve the interests of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement to make
sure that that peace process isn't
undermined by any damage to the
north-south Border but at the same time
no damage to the East-West border which
is of course an important strand of that
1998 agreement okay here come all the
acronyms the dup saying seven tests
including no border in the Irish sea no
checks on goods between GB and I and if
they don't support what's going forward
then the ERG
now the European research group another
acronym for you they are not going to
support it because they want the dup to
be happy so where does that leave the
prime minister
well I I I think the seven tests being
having been developed last year were an
important moment for the dup uh I've yet
to see and I think all of us have yet to
see the detail of that deal maybe I'll
be the dup keep their Council of some
performance well I think it'll be a vast
Improvement in where we were if we have
red and green Lanes I think I think the
problem here okay is that we have a
unique situation in Northern Ireland we
have a peace process we've got to
maintain that north-south border must
never be a hard border and that does
mean that the rules of the single Market
do start to blend uh in a you know
rather unusual and perhaps in elegant
way with the rules and the laws of the
United Kingdom there therefore needs to
be a compromise I think within those
seven tests the dup I think do
understand that this is a unique
position and
um you know we've now in early 2023 it's
we've moved on I think the position that
meant that the government was right back
in June last year to bring forward its
own unilateral legislation here in
Parliament has changed that the fact
we're having meaningful negotiations the
fact that EU themselves acknowledge
problems with the protocol I think was a
big step forward and that does mean that
we're now in a place where we can
normalize relations which will have
wider implications for the UK we can
start to do business on small boats for
example if we can get this deal over the
line to be an oven ready deal and no
border whatsoever in the Irish sea
that's what a previous conservative
prime minister promised us well I I
would say that in the main we got the
absolute deal we wanted I think the
protocol was always going to be a
problem I think that some of the uh
practical effects of the protocol have
now uh demonstrated real dislocation of
course not all of the protocol has even
been brought into Force yet and I think
that would be an even more problematic
situation to be Einstein to realize it
was going to be a problem well I don't
think any of us were denying the fact
that this was a complex and a unique
situation in Northern Ireland but what I
think is it is encouraging to see is the
government prepared to seize the
initiative get on with those meaningful
negotiations and now hopefully today we
can see them bearing fruit so
how come
potentially a richly soon I can get this
over the line and Boris Johnson couldn't
well look that was a big sign I'm not
answering this question I'm not in the
room hey I'm not in the room I don't
have the advantage this time of being in
the rooms where where you know decisions
are made or information is is is is
passed on what I would say is that I
think this prime minister has been able
to create a relationship of trust uh I
think about personalities well sometimes
politics is and you know this isn't a
reflection on previous Prime Ministers
particularly you know if you get on well
with people and win their trust then I I
think in all our experiences more
business can be done and I think the
relationship with the French president
has probably improved I think there is
that willingness well I think I I
haven't been in a room with either them
together but but I understand that there
is a good personal chemistry and that
the relationship is a healthy one that's
really important if we are to make
progress on things like small boats okay
I think it's vital for the interests of
the UK at this time of economic pressure
that we are able to show the world that
we are capable of making deals and
agreements like the one I hope will
emerge this week and I think that is
good not just for Northern Ireland but
also good for Britain's reputation in
the world our relationship with the
United States and indeed The Wider
position of Britain so that's why I'm
willing the Prime Minister on and I very
much hope that a deal can be reached so
just to clarify we've got a conservative
prime minister who is finally listening
to what the European Union has to say
well I think they're listening to us as
well I think this time last year the
commission and indeed other governments
the Irish government weren't really in a
position where they were prepared to
admit that there was a problem with the
protocol that changed we heard much more
positive noises from the Irish
government and the EU themselves then
showed a willingness to share data and
to come to the negotiating table for
those formal talks I think both sides
have shown a willingness to compromise
and to come to a sensible agreement and
that's why I think we should be
welcoming the news today I just clarify
why do we cite a deal if we thought that
it wasn't the right deal
well if you remember back in 2019 I
think we were in a position where we
really needed to get a deal over the
line I think that in the main I think
that deal was an extremely sensible one
for the United Kingdom we got brexit
done in early 2020 we created that
transition period we got a trade
agreement that indeed in many elements
was was a deeper Trade Agreement than
perhaps people had originally thought
I'd love to go further I'd like to see
more subjects covered like financial
services for example in the future but I
do remembering our position at the time
I think it was uh very important that we
got a deal with the EU and managed to
keep that timetable which bearing in
mind the previous frustrations that we'd
seen about brexit was indeed an
achievement of Boris Johnson how can you
say we've got brexit done when was it
was where we are today
well I think I think the very Factor
brexit has been done but here's the
thing hey I think our relationship with
the EU will be a continuing negotiation
they're geographically next door to us
we have a lot of trade and relationships
in common between them we will continue
to talk bilaterally with the EU and
frankly that's what I want to see I
think the idea that somehow we shut up
shop and say well thank you very much
we're not going to be talking to you
anymore is I think uh rather a dangerous
concept I want to see more meaningful
discussions with the EU in future so
that we can enjoy that healthy bilateral
relationship outside of the institutions
of Brussels it's Robert it's always
great to see you thank you for joining
us thank you coach appreciate it thank
you